täglich treffen wilderer mindestens
einer soll in südafrika
im busch herrscht deshalb krieg
ranger und wilderer rüsten auf
wir brauchen neue wege sagt vince
barkasse er schützt wildtiere
in den 30 jahren die ich das mache haben
wir weder erschossen an gesperrt
verprügelt die haben alles getan aber
wir haben uns nun zusammengesetzt und
geredet
reden statt schießen könnte das helfen
krüger nationalpark südafrikas nirgendwo
leben mehr breitmaulnashörner in freier
wildbahn als hier und nirgendwo werden
so viele abgeschlachtet grund ist die
nachfrage in asien
ob aus aberglaube oder als statussymbol
ein einzelnes horn bringt auf dem
schwarzmarkt 1000 euro
flick groß so ist ermittler im krüger
nationalpark
mit einem metalldetektor sucht er nach
der kugel ein wichtiges beweismittel für
die ballistik sie kann zu der waffe
führen mit der geschossen wurde
groß so kann die toten nashörner dir
untersucht hat kaum noch zählen
ich selbst hatte in 25 jahren mehr als
1000 es ist nicht schön das zu sehen
auch wenn man sich an den gestank der
kadaver gewinnt trotzdem so was ist nie
schön vor allem wenn du weißt dass die
zahl der nation alarmieren schnell nach
unten geht
dieses nashorn war wohl schon tot als
die wilderer die hörner abschnitten doch
manchmal überlebt ein tier den schuss
wilderer schießen ungern zweimal sie
wollen nicht noch mehr aufmerksamkeit
erregen
wenn es nicht dass durch fakten sie die
wirbelsäule oder die achillessehne damit
es nicht weglaufen kann und rändern die
haaner ab in den vergangenen zehn jahren
rotteten wilderer allein im krüger park
mehr als 67 prozent des bestandes aus
verzweiflung hat jetzt auch der krüger
park mit dem sogenannten die horning
begonnen die nashörner sollen aus der
luft betäubt werden
dabei entdeckt das team ein nashorn
kadaver von dem die ranger noch nicht
wussten die hörner fehlen auch dieses
tier gebildet
dann ist es soweit
der pfeil trifft
wenig später liegt das nashorn am boden
der tierarzt wird das horn abtrennen
schmerzen hat das nashorn dabei nicht
die idee kein helm kein profit so ist es
für wilderer uninteressant
das horn ist ähnlich wie fingernagel es
wächst nach damit es nicht zu groß wird
muss man es etwa alle zwei jahre absägen
doch die maßnahme ist teuer hier im
krüger park kann nur ein teil der tiere
entwurmt werden
das ist in der regel an den grenzen des
parks außerdem haben einen höheren wert
als menschen
die maßnahme ist umstritten weil man die
natürlichen zustand des tieres ändert
und weil bilder immer wieder auch
entfernte tiere töten
hatten enthronte tiere trotzdem die
bilder wurden meist nicht ob sie es
taten walser doppel nicht sehen das ist
kein hort
damit sie nicht noch einmal ein paar
folgen das comeback die maßnahme ist aus
purer not geboren jede betäubung ist ein
risiko dieses weibchen hat probleme der
tierarzt spritzt ein gegenmittel
siehst du wie sie bebt und zittert es
das hilft dagegen und hilft ihr zu atmen
es kehrt die mobilisierung teilweise um
die wir gegeben haben so dass es hier
besser geht an das maximum
das horn wird registriert und
weggeschlossen manche private
landbesitzer haben unzählige horner doch
der handel damit ist verboten sie
fordern eine legalisierung die einnahmen
könnten in den kampf gegen die wilderei
fließen doch das risiko des missbrauchs
ist zu hoch sagen experten
wir halten das nicht für machbar so
lange es keinen starken
kontrollmechanismus gibt der es möglich
macht dass horn nachzuverfolgen vom
ursprungsland unterwegs und bis ins
zielland den gibt es derzeit schlichtweg
nicht
für den moment gilt lieber ein tier ohne
horn als eines das wegen seines horns
getötet wird
eine lösung auf dauer ist es nichts man
bekämpft symptome nicht die ursache
windsbacher sucht langfristige lösungen
vor über 30 jahren gründete einer anti
wilderei einheit pro track das konzept
schwer bewaffnete ranger die wilderer
ergreifen bevor sie zuschlagen können
heute glaubt er dass das allein nicht
reicht
in den 30 jahren die ich das mache haben
die wilderer erschossen ist eingesperrt
verprügelt wir haben alles getan aber
wir haben uns nie zusammengesetzt und
geredet
ranger sterben wilderer sterben leute
sterben lasst uns nach wegen suchen das
zu verhindern und unsere wird ihre
anlass zu schützen
gemeinsam mit seinem sohn dylan will er
sich mit will daran treffen dellen
barcas arbeitet für die hemmersbach
renault force einer aus deutschland
finanzierte schutzorganisation für
wildtiere die renault force und pro
track die organisation seines vaters
arbeiten hand in hand die beiden sind
auf dem weg nach mosambik der osten des
krüger parks grenzt an das nachbarland
ihr ziel ist massen
von hier kommen viele der wilderer die
in südafrika nach serner türken die
armut ist groß in massen der ganze ort
profitiere von der wilderei sagt barcas
die ganze stadt ist ihm wohl bis sie
alle pro partie und irgendwie von diesem
es trägt die komplette wirtschaft weil
die schulden verputzten häuser die ihr
seht das ist alles nachsorge es gibt
keine andere halter was ihm die ihr geld
über die
winz baak assist hier um zu treffen so
lohmann roubini es heißt er sei ein kind
bin der dritthöchste bilder im ort einer
der seine teams zum bildern in den park
schickt die beiden haben sich vorsichtig
angefreundet aus ihren gesprächen
entstand ein hilfsprojekt heute wird
eine plattform für eine pumpe gebaut
damit sollen später felder bewässert
werden um die lebenssituation der
menschen zu verbessern
die armut sei der grund warum gebildet
wird sagt immobilie
jemand der junge habe und keinerlei
einkommen könnte sich entschließen in
den bus zu gehen weil es auch nicht
kümmert er gefasst oder getötet wird
allein in massen hier wurden hunderte
wilderer festgenommen oder getötet
zurückgeblieben sind zahllose frauen und
kinder um sie geht es in dem
hilfsprojekt dass die hemmersbach
renault fonds finanziert
sie haben viele männer oder onkel und
väter durch nashorn wilderei verloren
unterstützen sie in dem wir dieses stück
land führen
für den anfang soll sich
aber auch etwas
für diese familien geht es teilweise um
die existenz nicht so für die king pence
auch salomon bobigny habe ganz unten
angefangen heißt es für andere king
pence nashörner getötet vor der kamera
erklärt er habe mit wilderei nichts zu
tun seine beziehung zu tieren beschreibt
er so
ich kann sagen meine beziehung zu tieren
ist dieselbe wie meine beziehung zum
wohnen
tiere sind nahrung sowie wir samen in
die erde sehen die deine früchte trägt
das ist mein ziel mich zitieren
wie er denken viele in massen bäume sind
feuerholz tiere sind nahrung nach geld
wer hier aufwächst fährt nicht mit
seinen eltern in den nationalpark um die
schönheit der tiere in freier wildbahn
zu erleben
für so etwas fehlen die mittel
die armut ist auch ein erbe der
kolonialzeit die ungleichheit die aus
rassistischer diskriminierung entstand
existiert bis heute und zeigt sich eben
auch wenn es um wildtiere geht das gilt
nicht nur für mosambik
wir haben quartiere zu einer sache für
reiche weiße gemacht vor 30 jahren im
lotto spielen und unser wasser besitzt
und wir haben schwarze menschen außen
vor gelassen auf der anderen seite das
diesen ansatz müssen wir ändern
so roubini sieht das auch so die
schmerzen die rund um die parks leben
hätten nichts von den wildtieren sagt er
mehr noch
die tiere werden als wertvolle angesehen
als wir menschen
das verursacht viele probleme wenn man
uns nicht berücksichtigt
das projekt ist aus seiner sicht ein
schritt in die richtige richtung
salomon baehny soll angeboten haben
seine waffen auszuhändigen wenn das
projekt funktioniert
zurück in südafrika manche glauben ich
sei verrückt sagt vintz backers aber er
ist überzeugt dass er mit seinem weg des
dialogs und der hilfe mehr nashörner
rettet als in dem männer mit waffen in
den bus schickt
man sieht wie viel geld ausgegeben wird
zur munition waffen training zu diesen
wie viele menschen wenn wir in die
gebiete ging wo die bilder herkommen die
wirtschaft und geschäfte aufbauten den
schulen bei der bildung helfen würde
dann gäbe es deutlich weniger leute die
versuchen unsere tiere zu töten
doch dieser weg braucht geld politischen
willen und st für die afrikanischen
nashörner könnte es zu spät sein und
solange die armut rund um die punk so
groß ist wird sich immer jemand finden
der bereit ist ein nashorn zu töten